this is what parts of aldamir city in
Sudan's River Nile State look like now
heavy rains and flash floods have caused
widespread destruction hundreds of homes
and properties have been destroyed and
people left with nowhere to go
thank God we are safe but harm has been
done already we lost houses and
belongings in the flood but thank God
anyway
last week's Reigns had several other
areas in Riverdale State as well at
least four people were killed when flash
floods swept through their homes other
states have also witnessed heavy rains
and floods nearly 60 000 people have
been affected since the start of Sudan's
rainy season in June many are now in
desperate need of assistance
we need houses the situation is bad even
before the heavy rainfall it was bad
enough we want the government to help
the people here we have no income to buy
construction material but getting help
may be challenging five months of
conflict between the Army and the
paramilitary rapid support forces has
affected the response to those in need
of assistance the war has weakened the
economy and eight organizations are
struggling to get money to help people
affected by the war those devastated by
the floods may have to wait even as more
heavy rains are expected Heber Morgan Al
Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera